how's it going keith oh it's good how
are you doing i'm doing awesome where
are we going so we're going to vegas
we're going to vegas let's go
okay well i think i'm packed hey that
bag's okay for that
so steven brought me in the car
yesterday and just said we're going
somewhere pack your bags you haven't
really told me why we're in vegas we had
such a great time on that sushi
adventure yeah we had a great time
who's your boy
stephen lamb
yeah look gotta do part two so today
we're gonna get three types of burgers
cheap one a medium priced one and a
super expensive one in fact it's gonna
be 777
dollar
oh i'm allergic to that idea but we're
gonna find out is that burger really
worth the price different i like cheap
burgers maybe you just haven't had the
right experience yet with the right
person i like that you've made that
about you well isn't this all about
making no it's not it's literally a
video comparing burgers
with keith and steven best buddies for
life
i'm adam baird the executive corporate
chef for habitburger grill heath and
steven are out in las vegas enjoying a
delicious char burger we cook everything
to order and we season it with a
handmade seasoning in the back of the
house we caramelize onions all day long
toast our buns to order every little bit
of detail has to be executed with the
utmost skill it is gorgeous i don't want
to waste any time talking let's eat it
it smells so good i don't want to waste
any time talking let's eat it
right now
oh it's so juicy very savory the
mayonnaise was like this great layer of
delightful goodness your reaction after
taking a bite of this is to take another
bite immediately
this drink is delicious also they make
their own strawberry limeade here and
it's great go back and forth perfect
balance like an olympic gymnast you're a
perfect keith you can argue with that
together we are the perfect dynamic duo
and this burger is 4.15 that's crazy
what would you compare this value to
theft 415 you can't beat this burger but
the next burger's not four dollars it's
20 bucks so we gotta bring your family
here
bring a date why are you cutting me off
i had such a nice round i'm trying to
end the segment and then i have to start
over with a new bow why is this
happening you're not gonna
damn that was a fine boy
how many burgers did america eat in 2014
this is a question this is not a fact
that's trivia gets a burger [ __ ] and
asked me a question how many burgers
did america eat in 2014 i don't know 200
000. what are you stupid i don't i'm
guessing i was awaiting a fact nine
billion so on our way now to the gordon
ramsay burger wouldn't mind some bacon i
don't think we'll meet gordon but we'll
certainly meet somebody i'm driving
without hands keith it worries me
[Music]
we are at gordon ramsay burger our
featured burger today that we're talking
about is our hog burger this is the only
burger that we actually griddle we get a
lot more caramelization on it our buns
they're all brushed with 83 butter fat
and they are toasted on the griddle our
cabbage slaw is dressed with a tarragon
mayonnaise a nice beautifully
caramelized pork patty on top of our
pork is our smoked barbecue brisket on
top of the pork pork on pork on pork
then comes our crispy onion garlic
seasoning paprika and a little bit of
cayenne per kick and we also need the
acid of our pickles so these are our
house-made bread and butter pickles
massive it's almost as big as your head
the best thing about a burger is it's
simple everyone can identify with it but
the way that you can take it through the
roof is in the details when i eat
burgers that are this big i smash them
you are an animal how are you gonna
enjoy the flavors like that how are you
gonna enjoy the flavors separately
cheers
wow it's very very porky but with the
onions and the pickles totally counters
to find this many ingredients and put it
into one item that you can enjoy
together is a very hard task and they
managed to do that balance is like a pig
on a tightrope baby if i'm gonna spend
18 i want to see this much food it was
as big as steven's head but a really
sexy steven's head are you sure that's
not just this guy right here no i'm
pretty sure two little figgies with
steven lim heads on a tightrope i want
to see that animation now
if you were saying anywhere in your
planet hollywood and you want a bomb ass
burger this is just incredible now we
gotta head to this this preposterous
burger what would make this next burrito
worth it i guess it'd have to be the
best tasting burger i've ever had that's
not hard to do right it is hard to do
i've eaten more burgers than any other
food it's too expensive no amount of
money can buy the friendship that we
have together heath you hear that i bet
all the people on the internet are so
envious of our friendship
what we're looking at today is our 777
burger the best hamburger in town it's
777 it is that is the most expensive
burger i've ever heard of and champagne
fan shape because it comes with don't
pair in yellow that burger gets a wagyu
patty aged goat cheese shredded bacon oh
my god fall raw arugula lobster and it
gets 100 year old aged balsamic vinegar
how much is a bottle this goes for about
200 a bottle i'm looking at it and like
every single item on there is more
expensive than the thing i would
normally eat you gotta live once in a
while i know i gotta live i'm you gotta
live we are about to eat the greatest
thing in the world for once i'm not
super upset that you're touching me
because i i too are very excited that's
not an invitation to re-grab good
afternoon gentlemen i just wanted to
stop by and offer you first our bottle
of dom perignon rose and this goes
exquisitely with the finest burger on
the planet the 777 burger yes you made a
wonderful decision today gentlemen enjoy
your meal i also like how romantic this
is that we're going to share everything
it's very cute i'm sorry i couldn't
afford more than one burger no i
understand which is actually my plan all
along okay you eat it first keith i
can't you sure i don't feel worthy
i want some of that champagne though
well that's delightful oh that's good
holy
i'm going for it
wow
stephen that is crazy tasting i had so
much pleasure just watching you eat that
burger it's really good i don't want to
eat it eat it i can't i i feel i
physically cannot eat this burger i feel
bad
[Music]
i'm tearing up watching you eat this
dude it's so good balsamic vinegar is
truly
like god tears i'm doing it
[Music]
it's a little overwhelming wow every
item on here has a strong flavor the
goat cheese and the beef really melt
together well it's like one true pair
like keith and steven all together you
know it's best buddies for life he's
insane let's not kid ourselves that's a
lot of money but if you're in a place to
spend lots of money might as well go for
it and i didn't think that a burger
could be an experience until today i
don't want this ever to end so
what was your favorite if i were to come
back to vegas and bring my girlfriend
somewhere it would have to be the gordon
ramsay burger
it was something super different and it
was a really just really good burger i'm
gonna start going to the habit however
the best burger i had today was the
seven seven
you know to share bites of that burger
it's worth it it's vegas baby
do that i'm gonna go to bed it's 5 30 in
vegas you can sleep but i'm getting it's
burgers
baby all right you're scaring me i'm
going to sleep vegas baby